man dude I went with him when he found
Japan and the Japanese fans loved him
instantly really loved them
I was a bit jealous damn like that it
took him a while to like love me like
that he came out with the samurai suit
oh oh that tried his his walkout was
fine dude he's the only person that had
like a hundred thousand dollar walkouts
uniform yeah he's funny because he came
on my show right before he came World
Champ and uh he was like yeah man I just
want to win and then uh I have a GT2 or
that support she's like yeah I'm gonna
take the money I'm gonna buy that I'm
like oh no no don't waste all your money
on a car yeah yeah gradually get there
yeah because he's a Gearhead too he
loves cars yeah he loves cars yeah I
don't I see I see like him and his dad
talk I think his dad do the same thing I
do sometimes all right you're gonna
learn the hard way